primero que todo lo felicito por el
triunfo de la Selección Argentina y
comienzo preguntándole Cuál es el
balance que hace usted de Qatar como
sede y organizador de esta Copa del
Mundo Hola Santiago Muchas gracias este
estamos muy felices en la tierra de los
nuevos campeones del mundo de fútbol el
balance que se hace es contradictorio
creo que fue un mundial
raro pero para los argentinos tuvo un
final feliz un final de película con
un partido el último el de que nos
brindaron Argentina y Francia que es una
de las mejores finales de la historia de
los mundiales por lo menos de los muchos
que yo vi en
el escenario o por televisión desde
México
1970 tuvo de todo Buen fútbol
polémicas este jugadas impecables y
goles de como el segundo que hizo este
Di María para la Selección Argentina y
un jugador exquisito como Lionel Messi
que a quien Dios le regaló lo que le
faltaba que era besar y levantar la copa
del mundo ahora sabe cuánto pesa ese
trofeo tan ambiciado por todos los que
aman este deporte Julio
Qatar tuvo la oportunidad de darse aquí
visibilidad internacional toma cierta
ventaja con sus vecinos y rivales
digámoslo así estamos hablando de los
emiratos árabes Unidos de bahrein y
otros países del Golfo Pérsico Cómo
cambia la imagen de un país después de
haber sido sede de un mundial usted tuvo
la experiencia de El caso argentino en
el 78 por ejemplo
Sí por supuesto
bueno Ahora hay que ver qué es lo que
sale a la luz si van a salir todas las
cosas que se taparon Durante este
mundial como las denuncias hechas por
los organismos de derechos humanos y por
la
organizaciones de trabajadores este
sobre los las condiciones paupérrimas y
las muertes que hubo en la construcción
de los estadios como hablamos en
oportunidad anterior Santiago te
recuerdas o este todo se tapa con el
festejo y
la la gran este fiesta que se vivió en
cada uno de los estadios con las
elecciones que tuvieron mayor apoyo
primero fueron México Argentina después
se sumó Marruecos pero hubo muy pocos
este
fanáticos de Europa claro los europeos
le hicieron un
el mundial de Qatar y no fueron en masa
como en otros mundiales sí Julio
préstame atención a esta alineación que
le voy a decir alineación de fichas como
si estábamos hablando de fútbol Messi
mbappé el psg el Emir de Qatar inversión
en este equipo francés se consolida
Entonces catar como un país importante
en la industria futbolística a nivel
internacional no en el tema competitivo
porque la selección salió en la primera
ronda pero por lo menos Sí para mover
fichas y para financiar este deporte
yo creo que ya lo hizo porque tiene
intereses en clubes en la Premier tiene
en el psg tienen el Milan Así que va a
seguir acentuando tu invasión a con
capitales en los equipos más importantes
y en las figuras más destacadas de este
deporte